a bipartisan group of New York City
council members are demanding Governor
Kathy Hogle sue the Biden Administration
over the record flow of migrants in the
city the common sense caucus wrote
private and public appeals to the White
House for assistance had been met with
indifference or silence we believe the
president and his administration have
left you no choice but to go to the
courts for redress New York city
councilwoman Joanne Ariola signed on to
that letter and she joins us now
councilwoman good morning to you so this
is a bipartisan effort do you think
Governor Hogle will be receptive to this
call
she hasn't been receptive to all our
other letters but we will continue to
send yes this is a bipartisan effort the
common sense caucus where six
Republicans and two Democrats wow and
the money that this
flood of illegal immigrants into New
York is costing taxpayers is
unbelievable New York City taxpayers are
taxpayers are on courses spend about
forty thousand dollars per migrant which
is an estimated total cost of five
billion dollars which is more than any
other Sanctuary city in the country and
now you have New York city mayor at Eric
Adams saying that this could destroy the
city
he did say it could destroy the city I
say it has destroyed the city we are
real we need to come back and that's why
this this legal action that needs to be
taken by the governor against the
federal government for their failure to
secure our borders and prevent the flow
of migrants into our city and state is
the only way we can really really fix
the problem handle the problem that we
already have and end the constant influx
of migrants into our city yeah yeah
we're getting on average just under 10
000 migrants per month we currently have
113 300 migrants who've entered our our
respite and intake centers this is
unsustainable it is absolutely
unsustainable and there are those that
would make the argument that it is sort
of a problem of New York's own making
because it is a sanctuary state New York
City is a sanctuary City what would you
say to those people
I'd say that they're right this is a
result of the radical left agenda that
had been in office prior to to uh this
particular Administration and me
becoming a council member and now we're
paying the price for it we can only hope
that the courts uh agree that um the the
right to shelter should be amended or
revoked for this period of time while
we're going through this crisis but we
cannot continue to spend the billions
and billions and billions of dollars
that we don't have and Kathy hulkel's
answer to that is ask Joe Biden to use
our National Historic Parks like Floyd
Bennett Field to house 7 500 male single
individual migrants I know it's absolute
negligence I know and I can see why what
other Governor would offer up their
national parks yeah or military bases
yeah military military base I know
that's also happening as well so what
will New York New York City look like in
five years if this level of illegal
immigration continues to pour into the
city
it will be a tent city because everyone
who lives here will have left when you
when you when you really look at all the
different numbers we have the most
migrants of any other large city Miami
has 69 000 plus Chicago 40 000 La 62
000. we have 113
300. it is impossible for a locality to
take care of a a humanitarian migrant
Asylum whatever you want to call this
crisis it's impossible for a locality to
take care of it the governor and the and
the president created this crisis and
they're doing little to nothing to help
our city and all they want to do is to
keep our borders open keep the flow
coming in and when you're offering free
room free board free free health care
free education iPads phones and the
potentiality of work permits we're
actually
enticing people to come here
yeah and it's just it has to say yeah
this is a bipartisan effort because
there is bipartisan outrage over this
and you can you can see why councilman
thank you so much for joining us this
morning
thank you for the time I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis